so thank you for the introduction and
thank I'm very excited to come here and
speak here I've been trying to follow
the work that is coming out of here and
very excited about seeing kind of very
fresh ideas that that are relevant to
the work that we are doing I'm I'm
teaching at the Shin Cal College in in
Ramat Gan which is just outside Tel Aviv
and and I'm volunteering with an NGO
called the public knowledge workshop who
that is doing work on civic engagement
and government transparency in Israel
anyway what I'm going to talk about
today is the thing I've been working
with for the last decade or so and
developed through my years in New York I
spent five years in New York between
2005 and 2010 and this is kind of a
theme that as a designer I've been
working with for for many years now so
I'm going to discuss the theme of
interface and maybe the politics of
interface through the communication
cycle the idea of protocols and and then
I'll try to suggest interfaces for
resistance and ways ways for that to be
addressed as well when we're talking
about life online you know we have we
have the all of the euphemism it's
distributed it's open it's an
interactive participatory Democratic
social emancipatory right at the same
time when we're talking about online
life we're talking about destructing
controlling intrusive abusive regret
repressive shallow like all of these
terms or all of these hopes all of these
concerns when it comes to online life we
meet them through the interface so the
interface is there is this point of
interface between between us and all of
this technology right it sits at the
heart of the of the debate so what is
interface so there are many definitions
that the one that I find interesting is
a common boundary or interconnection
between systems equipments concepts and
human beings this is one of many many
definitions but I think one part of it
that very that I think makes sense and
communicates specifically is this idea
of common boundary and interconnection
and and the this idea of of the
interface being something common
something that we share is that
something that we connect through imply
some kind of relationship with between
these these system equipments concepts
human being says so and it doesn't imply
necessarily a level of of control it
does it doesn't imply that one side
should be stronger than the other so on
and and it has to do you know this idea
of commonality is something that has
been discussed through media studies and
before for many years this idea of
mutuality and interconnectedness and you
know the the the code that there's this
idea of the classic the classic model of
the communication cycle we have it's
like in Sesame Street right do I have an
idea I talked to you you have the idea
you have an idea he talked to me we both
have idea now now the two of us have two
ideas how great so this is Stuart Hall
in 1980 he wrote he wrote a paper called
encoding/decoding and at the heart of
his of his paper he was this critique of
of this of this communication cycle
he was he was saying that this is this
is actually not the way it works
he called it he said this is basically
too too simplistic what is happening
there is a bit more complex he called a
called this textual determinism because
because the this idea that will be that
one side can plant ideas kind of drag
and drop into the mind of a different of
another person that's that's not how
communication actually works
any-any try to focus on the process of
how a communication happens and he said
first of all does encoding I have an
idea
I encode it into into a different form
in the in the case of this illustration
into speech so the idea is turned into
sounds so the this body of knowledge is
in encoded into sound and the sound is
or is definitely not the body of
knowledge and as long as we have
meaningful discourse as long as you can
hear me and understand my funny accent
and so on
if if you're in the back and you can't
hear me well then we don't have
meaningful meaningful discourse in this
room in the front but but but the point
is that the this is assuming you can
actually hear me right and and
understand me to turn to an acceptable
level and then there's the process of
decoding decoding sound for listening in
this case into a new body of knowledge
so this so if in Sesame Street it was
like I had a triangle and now you have a
triangle so I have a triangle and what
you have is not a triangle anymore it's
different I don't know what it is you
don't really know what I had in my brain
the this process but both the encoding
process and the decoding process are
creative processes it's processes where
the the information changes and
and I was really interested in that well
Stuart Hall was a was writing about
about television specifically that was
in 1980 that was the medium that was
being researched and and there were a
lot of concerns about what does the
television do and he referred to three
types of code he was saying one way of
decoding is through a dominant or
hegemonic code so the the recipient the
the decodes the message using the same
code it was encoded in so as is
basically as so think weather or sports
by a broadcast or a certain type of
radio taco like radio hosts okay that
that whatever they say is is being
accepted as is so when I'm when I'm
listening to the two sports forecast for
example I don't ask myself well they
said it was a touchdown but is it really
a touchdown okay it's it's not really
relevant in some cases it is relevant to
question the message but but the
hegemonic code would would be kind of
accepting everything that is there the
negotiated code is more critical yet not
completely dismissive of the reading
think I guess the NPR okay so you don't
you
NPR claims it doesn't have a liberal
bias you know it has a liberal bias but
but but you you see yourself as
intelligent enough to spot it okay but
but it's still useful it's still useful
to listen to it you you know you you you
take what what you can get and then
there is the oppositional code so the
oppositional code in the opposition code
the message becomes an opportunity to
deconstruct the code
think a feminist reading of a little red
riding-hood or the Sex Pistols god save
the queen or all the Hitler gets angry
meme okay so we know that what what the
original message was supposed to be but
we use the we refer to the original
encoding in a specific employee
different way most memes actually are
somewhat oppositional and for me I'm
really interested in what happens when
it's when it's not conversational
television what happens when
communication is structured through
interface and specifically web
interfaces so when when the message is
encoded when we see in a message on on
the web its encoded through the
interface so we all celebrate and enjoy
how how expressive the Internet is and
how expressive the tools of the internet
are but but this expression is in the
level of creating these web pages right
when when it comes to the decoding of
the of this message messages it's
basically the same idea you you get the
message you decode it you understand
what you understand from it so far
pretty much the same model the thing is
what happens when we're trying to encode
our message to the to the Internet's or
to the to a web page when we respond to
it to the system or the website it is
always through the system's dominant
interface so so if if interface is the
part is an important part of how we
communicate we online we don't actually
get to choose what interface to use we
we basically work within the constructs
of the of the interface that we were
given and I'll give you an example for
to make it a bit more like simpler to
understand so so this is from a friend
of mine Leila Haddad
the Palestinian blogger and journalist
and she she tried to order flights
flight tickets on a British Airways and
she you you all probably came across
this drop down what is your nationality
so she's looking down the list to find
her national nationality and under P
there's no Palestinian nationality and
that is being there done that so the the
interface demands the this this level of
of obedience it's like this is who who
you can be but but they but the
interface actually also teaches
obedience because if you come into a
problem like that you know that's where
you call you call the the company
support right so she called the support
of British Airways and and the person on
the other side was saying okay I'm
looking at my system and in mice in that
person system there was another
drop-down menu with no Palestinian
identity so or or nationality or
passports or documents or whatever so
it's even even when you talk to a human
that conversation is kind of mitigated
through through the interface and in in
that case the in in that sense so the
the same dominant interface was there as
well
Lisa Nakamura who's who's researching a
lot of how race race online basically
she calls it menu driven identities
interfaces that limit and define what we
are allowed to be think how many years
it took for Facebook to accept different
types of general definitions so it's the
same thing it's like why is that drop
drop down menu why can I only be one of
these things right yeah so let's talk
about protocol
to understand the role of user interface
we need to dive deeper into into the
communication protocol this work is
inspired by by the work of Alex Galloway
and and other thinkers on the on this
topic but but specifically I'm trying to
think what is different about the web in
that sense so when we're talking about
traditional media we're talking about
centralized protocol broad broadcast
one-to-many that's a consistent protocol
so so television is always one too many
okay
same with newspapers and broadcast radio
that the fact that it's consistent means
that the question of the interface in in
the television case is not a it's not
that big of an issue when you understood
the interface of the television you
understood it's consistent you can move
on same with an interactive protocol
like telephone right so this is a
one-to-one it's interactive but but it's
still a consistent protocol it's a
protocol that doesn't change every time
I pick up the phone when we when we're
going to digital media we have different
kinds of protocols we have email we have
chat we have network games we have voice
over IP and all of these in this example
all of them actually have a consistent
protocol when I'm sending an email
I always need an address it should be at
something and so on the I am not I'm not
getting every email trying to ask myself
what am I supposed to do now and when
when talking about protocols there's the
idea of the seven layers of the OSI
model so they are the OSI model is kind
of technical but but but the things
which we should care about the this is
the the protocol of the Internet the
different layers of the protocol of the
Internet the there's we we have the
protocol layer that that's where the
tcp/ip lives that that's basically how
packet switching happens and and and
basically everything that we know about
the internet being networked and so on
happens there I want getting too much
into that but the top layer of the of
the OSI model is the application layer
so so that's where we have our different
applications like email clients voice
over IP network games and so on and also
a browser so when we open the browser I
think something slightly different
happens because the the browser's
protocol is flexible on the web the
protocol is basically a question of
interface every web page basically adds
another layer of of protocol another
layer of possible control and I would
suggest that that the OSI model needs to
be updated with another layer when we're
talking about the web with a layer of
interface specifically user interface if
in the application layer we're using a
browser then then we can get different
kinds of applications that really
changed the way we should think about
about control and communication online
and we have to to take into account the
interface question is a governance
question it's it's a question of who
sets the rules who who's supposed to be
abiding by these rules what is the
process of making rules so you've
probably noticed that this is kind of
the Media Studies
inspired thing and and I tried but I
couldn't resist
including Marshall McLuhan and yeah so
let's listen what he has to say
between the old
the medium does things to people and
they're always completely unaware of
this
they don't really notice the new medium
that is wrapping them up they into the
old medium because the old medium is
always the content of the new medium as
movies are tend to be the content of TV
and as books used to be the content
novel just to be the content of movies
and so every time a new medium arrives
the old medium is the content and it is
highly observable highly noticeable but
the real real wrapping up and massage is
done by the new medium and it is
ignorant that's you know his classics
peel the the old medium is the content
of the medium new medium so the books
books have become the content of film
film have become the content on of TV
and then TV have become the contact the
content of the web right well not only
right basically there's a lot of things
going on on the web not just not just
the previous medium not just the oldham
the medium so for in a sense we can say
the this is what what McLuhan meant by
the medium is the message but that but
that's only true as long as the the
medium has a consistent protocol because
because I would say that the media the
medium is the message when we're talking
about the kind of of media that we have
today we can think about it as interface
the determinism it kind of determines
that the by pointing at the medium we
are also pointing at the interface
maybe the interface is the message maybe
that's what McLuhan actually meant in he
never it just never thought of me of
media having different interfaces which
is what we have right now so
the met may be a the message and the
rules that govern it becomes ambiguous
as when when they when the interface
kind of changes every time and and this
is obviously all kind of adopting from
from McLuhan can only go so far because
I don't really share his techno
determinism but but but but basically
this is a kind of a response to him so I
I'd like to bring up another very
important and influential thinker Donald
Rumsfeld trying to make the case they
for the work in Iraq and referring to
the question of WMDs Rumsfeld went on an
interesting philosophical statement that
you probably remember there are known
knowns there are things that we know
that we know there are known unknowns
there things that we've done that we
know that we don't know but there are
also unknown unknowns they'll think that
we don't know that we don't know things
that uh so far from what we can even
imagine and that's a good reason to go
to war without proof of WMDs now now
when when Slavoj Zizek saw came across
this it was too tasty for him to to
ignore and he enjoyed the rhetoric but
but it's but he said basically this is
great but Rothfeld forgot the four the
fourth option there are unknown knowns
what about the things that we don't know
that we know so this is the the real
reason for the war the sub-conscience
that's what ideology happens and
Dziedzic actually writes about the fact
that that's what design happens that
that's that's how design works design
uses the unknown known the things that
we don't know that we know
things that work on us without us
knowing and I would I would add that's
how interface works so when it comes to
to user interface design and usability I
think Steve Steve Krug would they would
agree but the Disco's in interaction
design is trying to keep the unknown to
keep the the known unknown so the the
fact that we don't know that we know is
kind of good for for interaction design
at least in the in the professional
debate and Steve Krug wrote one of the
Bible's of user interface and and this
is its title don't make me think I'm
sure some of you have come across it and
it was published in 2000 and widely
quoted inversely translated book and
that has framed a lot of the discourse
about the role of interaction designers
lowering the cognitive load to a minimum
and and that is actually you know let's
put things in perspective that is true
to a certain degree and one of the terms
that we speak about in interaction
design is affordance affordance is how
interfaces or how tools communicate what
you can what you're expected to do with
them so so but but but then the question
that should be asked is is it what
attention do we afford or in the case of
the web how is our attention being
afforded because when attention becomes
the most real resource on the on the
internet we the the the attention is
becoming something something that we we
are we both use our attention but our
attention is being used it's being
afforded it's becoming a currency on the
web so we've established that there are
quite a few political issues involved
and and we are not as when we're coming
to the site we're not too much in a
position of affecting
them so so how can we basically try to
think of of interfaces for resistance or
or resisting the the paradigm of the
interface so I would suggest definition
a diffusion of tactical resistance
strategic resistance and logic logistic
this resistance so the first you know
the first around the so-called web 2.0
in the meet in the middle of around ten
years ago there was a lot of excitement
about about user-generated content
they're asking us what we think how
amazing is that and and it's like
authorship all of a sudden can happen
because because all of a sudden the
content of of the web is not just
content it's also interfaces that would
allow us to create content that's when
when the interface is kind of enough to
allow it's kind enough to allow us to
express ourselves so that I would call
that the the first depth of authorship
the second depth would be context so
user-generated context think about
mashups and bear embeds and this build
build into into the web protocol think
of we're taking a you know correctly
Craigslist posting and putting them on a
Google map that was a big deal when it
happened for the first time and and now
the creating the context of taking this
and that and putting them together is a
new layer of kind of a new type of
authorship and it's a this kind of
author authorship is built into the
web's protocol the idea that I can take
one one resource and another resource
and put them together that's how the web
works and the the same flexibility it's
the same flexibility that gives us also
trackers and ads and ad networks so so
it's not necessarily used in in our
behalf
and the third option I would suggest
would be user-generated interfaces this
is also built into the protocol of of
the internet having users change what
the site allows them to do usually by
modifying the browser mainly with the
browser extensions and and that is a
that the idea that you can come to you
can take your browser and you can change
it and then you can you can actually
redefine what this browser can do is is
something that can extend what we might
want to call interface literacy this
idea that it's not only about how do I
read the interface in front of me or how
do I a lower cognitive load but how do
how do I mitigate the this political
question of governance that happens on
the web so one way of addressing that is
the tactical resistance so the tactical
resistance would happen on the interface
layer this is a subversion of the
interfaces use I think the textbook
example for that would be Google bombing
so this was a around the around the time
of the of the attack at the beginning of
the war in Iraq this was a parody of of
the lack of not finding weapons of mass
destruction when when you when you
searched the web for weapons of mass
destruction you would get that as a
first result in Google and that that
happened by by a concerted effort from
from different different bloggers that
opposed the war they all wrote the words
weapons of mass destruction and linked
them to this page which met which raised
the the Google rank for the for this
page and made it the the first result
for weapons of mass destruction so
turning turning PageRank into an
interface PageRank is not supposed to be
an interface right or a user interface
so what represents this kind of tactical
resistance is this hit-and-run it's
limited in scope for better or worse
it's a limited investment for better or
worse a lot of hacking and culture
jamming happening happening in in this
in this level of resistance it's it's
about learning how the system works and
finding its vulnerabilities taking
advantage of the interface interfaces
openness so the interface is open to a
certain degree this is an opportunity
the kind of teaching the system
something you didn't know about itself
and most of most of these cases are
symbolic gestures of resistance so a
protester action and political art is is
mainly tactical in that sense the second
type of resistant would be strategic
resistance and I would suggest that
that's the kind of resistance that
happens in the application layer so that
is basically saying yes we're supposed
to be browsing the web through these
softwares let's try to see how can we
change that like how do we change the
browser itself so I deliberately chose
an example that is not political but
commercial so this is Bureau it was a
it's not active anymore but they're
quite a few similar ones
what book Bureau does is something that
Amazon would never do tell you about on
each book page where can you find the
book for a better price online and work
and where can you find it in public
libraries based on how far they are from
where you are right now so this we look
at that and say ah yeah I need that none
of us would even think to in the
direction of creating an interface like
that because that is what we need
because it's we will completely submerge
within the the politics of interface
that we are not a part of we are we're
not supposed to have agency there right
another example there is
the most popular anybody knows what's
the what the most popular extension on
both on firefox and chrome huh
adblock Pro definitely yeah so so a
block class
so this basically they as soon as
extensions become became a thing on
Firefox this happened because we don't
necessarily want to see ads and in some
cases we don't necessarily want to be
tracked by ads this is arguably one of
the reasons for a google for the google
chrome project adblock plus was one of
the biggest hurdles for Google AdWords
from extending and and Google had to be
in a position of leverage in front of
the Google in front of adblock plus it
was obvious that that a chrome could not
with all of the the euphemism around the
Google being a great supportive of
open-source chrome could not have
started with no extensions and and could
not could not ignore adblock plus and
say this is a browser with no adblock
plus but what they did because they're
smart they they created leverage in
front of of adblock plus as a disruption
and and they Google pays adblock plus do
how many of you know that most of you
don't know that
so Google pays adblock plus to have to
change one thing about its interface so
they've they've added adblock plus added
a checkbox that says allow in obtrusive
ads
so redefining the question of why do we
not want ads do we not want ads because
we don't want banners or do we not want
to be tracked it's it's completely
redefined through adblock plus now and
one of the reasons is one of the reason
there are a lot of forks to the adblock
plus project that don't have this
checkbox okay this is also one of the
things that make the makes the claim
that adblock plus is is blackmailing ad
networks true and undisclosed I can talk
about it later afterwards but but this
is one of the examples I can bring up is
my project together with Helen Eason
bellman and Daniel how a ad nauseam we
basically created an extension that work
works with your ad blocker every ad
blocked by a bio bio blocker is clicked
by ad nauseam so we're clicking all of
the ads on the under web basically
flooding flooding out the profiles that
the ad networks are constructing and
planting a lot of mistrust between
advertiser and ad networks I can talk
about it later afterwards so this
approach is more of a hit and stay
approach it's a larger score it has
larger scope for better or worse larger
investment for better or worse it's
about developing kind of alternative
services and it's a deeper and less
traditional reading of the protocol the
political value here goes beyond the
symbolic it's more than a gesture of
resistance it's a solid resistance to
the interfaces demand demanded obedience
a concrete political power to be
reckoned with and it's harder to make an
out career out of there just FYI and the
third layer is logistic resistance and
now we're talking about resisting the
Internet Protocol
changing the protocol is the in kind of
deep protocols deep technical protocol
that like the tcp/ip either through slow
bureaucratic processes or through a
revolution that's how big protocols
change and a hegemonic protocol like the
tcp/ip require if you if you get rid of
that you need you basically need to
create a new hegemony to replace it it's
it's a big political and powerful and
over often conservative process through
standards committees and when one
standard is replaced with a with anyone
it breaks everything above it so so this
is something that is kind of tough and
the example for for kind of attempts to
challenge the tcp/ip protocol is this I
mean I haven't seen any we we basically
we basically haven't seen serious
attempts to to say we can go beyond
tcp/ip and maybe I have maybe you you
are the crowd who can tell me no you're
wrong there's this and this and that and
I'm waiting to hear that after the talk
but but but but this I haven't I've seen
a lot of attempts for mesh networks and
and other things that are actually built
on top of TCP IP but and and none of the
approaches that that basically say
whatever was was invented back almost
like her basically half a century ago is
is is not the way to go okay so if
Gainey more Azov which is both it's his
he can be seen as both an important and
provocative thinker and an arrogant and
violent role a bit of both I guess he he
defines it as technological defeatism
and he this belief that sense a given
technology is here to stay there's
nothing we can do about it or
then get on with it and simply adjust
our knowns and and I think this critique
is actually very valuable there are
things that we don't like about the
protocols the way protocols are working
but we don't see enough serious attempts
to challenge them it's like this concept
that has been with us for 50 years and
it's as if this is the way we're
supposed to work from now on
and we so all of this a critique of
things that have to do with it with the
internet it's not like it's only online
it's not real like what do we even need
to worry about that so much but just try
to think how many hours do we spend in
front of these screens that the more
hours we spend around in front of these
screens this is our real life this is
this is basically
most of our day or well most of our work
days are in front of these screens and
then and then we we we spend more and
more time in front of governing
interfaces so our experience I would say
most of our daily experience in
contemplating Authority and new ruled
systems is in front of web interfaces
because when we're talking about the web
demanding obedience it's it's 24/7 right
it's every webpage that I open has the
the subliminal question of what am I
allowed to do here and I don't even ask
myself this is the unknown this is the
the fact that I'm constantly constantly
thinking about it constantly
or I'm constantly made not to think
about it that is the the most profound
experience of obedience that we that we
have on a daily basis on a page-by-page
basis so yeah 24/7 around the clock and
not only online so they so these we can
say away from keyboard these dominant
interfaces of country
they're not new and to just put it in
context the we can see some example from
for resistance to the two interfaces on
control that are not technological or or
not digital
so for tactical resistance we can look
at do you know this so they this is the
response to the hegemonic code of the
Iranian government as part of the of the
Iranian uprising in 2009 the the bills
were the the money bills were used as a
form of protest and with the with the
writings like death to the the dictator
and for freedom it it has become a real
problem more and more money bills are
changing hands with with political
statements that are that are against
so-called counter revolutionary or
counter counter counter revolutionary it
gets complicated with with Iran but the
money's money is not supposed to be an
interface for protest but they made it
into an interface of protest and nobody
is going to throw that to the garbage
even though Ozma denatured try to say
that every bill that that would have a
sign like that would not be accepted but
but the phenomena was so wide that they
couldn't do that we can think of
strategic resistance and and my example
here is rolling jubilee which is a very
strong heat and stay approach actually I
should have updated this slide because
it's much more than money that they've
raised but what they do is they're
basically bailing out the poor so the
way that death works you buy if there
are high risk deaths they they are being
traded between different banks and
different companies and they're traded
for much less than the death itself so
they
Thundra if but what Roebling rolling
jubilee does they fundraise to to buy
debts and strike them and when this
slide was take this screenshot was taken
just a bit more than half a million
dollars abolished more than or almost
twelve million dollars in there so this
is reading the interface for the for the
financial system and and saying we are
going to play that game but not in the
same way that it's expected and this is
changing things on the ground this is
these are these are people who are
getting their lives back and the third
layer the logistic resistance is is best
represented by by what's been happening
in the middle east so sometimes it looks
like it looks like this a very hopeful
attempt to say we all plant something in
you and in Tahrir Square and things
would be different
well get rid of that protocol and and we
have our ideas for a new protocol
sometimes it looks like this a bit more
gruesome and we've all seen much much
more gruesome pictures which I'm not
going to show you here so my neighbors
around the around the Middle East have
had enough of the protocols that govern
them Tunis Egypt Libya Yemen and others
got rid of all of the previous protocol
and what we're seeing now can be seen as
a protocol war redefining the rules of
play so to conclude even though the car
the conflict is unavoidable I find it
very interesting and quite important to
confront I address it in in my academic
and creative work through different
tactics and strategies specifically I
find the question of interconnectedness
to be critical especially from my
geopolitical perspective thank you
thanks for showing so I'll open the
floor up to questions
I think the liberty of starting so
you've painted surface almost teared or
layered approach to thinking about sort
of the strategic and tactical the
tactical strategic and logistic forms of
resistance to the assertive but the
obedience that you've laid out as
demanded I'm wondering whether and
you've sort of made a made a prompt at
least in the online sense to say that or
with the digital technologies to say
that that the logistic you don't have
good examples of where are you sort of
we're looking for the good examples of
it um I want to put I want to push you
to think about sort of why that is it's
one of them easier to do is one of them
easier to understand well the technology
affordance or assertive philosophical
words I think it's it's both and beyond
that it's it's the way the technological
world is constructed the the fact that
we are we are led into into these new
settings new political settings by by
companies who who have their own
interests there and and there are the
biggest players is is is a big problem
and it basically puts us in a point of
this advantage I think I also think you
know you're lucky enough to you know to
be in the US because the u.s. controls
the internet and and we are like from my
perspective not being an American
citizen I'm not in a position of
influence as you you guys are you know
we will see we're seeing that with the
whole debate around around you know
Snowden is the following American
citizens like hey is it okay to follow
me say it's it's yes because I'm like
closer to terrorism
potentially but but it's a
constitutional only protects citizens
it's definitely not on online like
definitely not the technological
governance that we built that is built
from a certain ideology to serve certain
ideology there's so much power info but
but the problem is the reason that I
referred back to to on-the-ground
physical activism or of the financial
system is because my concern is that if
we don't resist the the interfaces
online then we don't expect to resist
anything because that is where we learn
how to how to interact and how to and
that's who that's what we learn what
what is expected from us on a civic
level and and and that is that is
concerning I can say that in in the case
of the of the way the technology
technological governance works but we've
we've come across it actually with the
ad nauseam the the project that I
mentioned I can actually if you want I
can play a three minute video for the
two and a half minute video for that
that actually addresses that point as
well okay
I don't know it's not my field so I
wouldn't know how to research that
exactly I I'm making the statement I'm
making is about political imagination to
certain degree that is limited by our
daily our daily experience of obedience
but so I'm I'm concerned about about our
ability to imagine different
relationships but but I don't I don't
know how to quantify that let's see
maybe someone else in the room
III don't know
with interface well basically what when
we the definition of interface has to do
with this connection between systems for
people we've experienced interface for
so long now and so intensely through
user interface that we forgot that we
forgot that there is no implied
hierarchy in the concept of interface
there could have been a web where they
were were the power settings of site
owners versus site users would have not
been set as as hierarchical so in its
core interface is about relationship and
about interconnectedness this point of
of yeah that's that's the connection
I want this to pull on the spray
lack of subversion of the ICANN board we
first that sending a very high bar even
constructing this protecting the people
who control the mechanism
but I would argue that there have been a
large number of attempts
who can argue that
letting packets that contain a certain
message go through I would argue that
you know let's shine and turned into a
distributed denial-of-service attack
that's supporting the got your partner
cause things like DNS poisoning with
everything a website resolution and we
know that people would talk about things
like so bad
the system is a limo effort to suppress
away
so I would I understand your point I
just I just think well at least the way
I'm seeing it this is using the tcp/ip
protocol this is what the tcp/ip
protocol allows that is basically maybe
not maybe not the way we would have
wanted or certain bodies would have
wanted to use it
but this is a use of that protocol this
is a part of the problems with that
protocol I would say the the way the
fact that privacy is not embedded into
the protocol is another problem with it
with that protocol beyond beyond the the
problem of a distributed denial of
service attacks or other or a packet
sniffing and the this is the protocol
this is what it allows if if this is
done within that context that this is
not challenging that that that protocol
by by saying here's another protocol
right it's it it's maybe but maybe
exposing maybe exposing the the
vulnerabilities of the of that protocol
but but not necessarily not necessarily
kind of directing another way for for
for for going beyond what the were the
protocol allows or does not allow yeah
yeah I would just put it in the in one
of the layers above the tcp/ip layer
that but I think we understand each
other I have is have to do with your
speak of interfaces and affordance and
and I do a lot of UX and I do a lot of
accessibility professionally for
patients and people in healthcare and
these are in my experience and this is a
question for you is you said you know
these interfaces asked us to obey the
in certain direction well just like in a
DDoS case I almost wanted some kind of
protocol to save me from these dogs
right but I didn't have any because I
have freedom quote unquote but now I
find the interfaces that are bad or that
are how should I put it
don't allow you to really do what you
meant to do or accomplish the tasks you
meant to accomplishes is what creates
that the relationship right I feel like
a lot of that disconnect is sloppiness
and not an agenda yeah so the question
for you just I have write an I deal with
the US government right now who is
forcing me to make it very universally
usable great right it sounds fantastic
but it comes from the government is a
mandate of set of rules I have to meet
or somehow prove to have met right but
it's kind of opposite to my sort of
general natural inclination of being a
cyber child to say no no I don't need
you to make me told me what to do I will
surpass your requirements I'll do
something they were different so I just
a question of you know sloppy versus
making it better for everybody sort of
individual choice versus a mandate so
yeah yeah this is if a version of this
question was was was made me yesterday I
gave a talk at Atmos art about this
information visualization or how to lie
with the nativist
and in my my argument there was was that
we should not look at visualization like
like Edward Tufte claims we should look
at it as a beautiful evidence we should
look at it as beautiful arguments and
and and I think I think it's about it's
about the argument it's not about like
interface of their to grab us all kind
of thing or and I actually I think that
don't make me think book is actually
good good in the sense that the the
there is a problem with cognitive load
and and it's a challenge cognitive load
can is a challenge for design but when
when we are so obsessed about directing
attention and and making our users not
think we also forget that we are we are
we we are representing different
interests now the interests of the site
owners and the different the the
interests of the users and I think the
example of book Bureau that's why I like
it so much because it because they're
the the difference of interest interest
there is so obvious when we are in the
position of designing these user
interfaces we are doing political work
we're doing work that should be
politicized so I'm I'm not going to
politicize you know bad interfaces like
it's not about making you think about
things that are not political a it's not
very McPeak crappy user your user
experiences just so you think about the
fact that is a crappy UX designer behind
it but but I do think that that if if
the what's embedded with within a
certain interface is is is something
that should be politicized the this
should be the the we should change the
way we think about what we are allowed
to do online that's that's more of of
the critic that I'm making
like is this because it seems
particularly important but now first to
say in like 2002 or something because of
the consolidation and sense of attention
on the Internet
so it seems like this is particularly
relevant when you're talking about like
website like amazon.com politicizing
amazon.com is really different than say
politicizing my personal blog or
something like that because so much of
the attention so much of the data flows
so much in personal data that is
captured and extract on the internet
flows to Amazon's and googles and
Facebooks and Twitter's and so on so I
mean do you feel like that's part of
this politics is this current sort of
geography of attention and data on the
Internet
yeah yeah it's it makes a lot of
difference but but but the basically the
the the playing with context on the
Internet has changed dramatically as
well out of the 100 most popular web
sites on the internet 97 of them report
back to Google about on everything that
you're doing and it's not like 97 out of
the 100 most popular sites are Google
Sites so even your blog has is exposed
to these questions and and they are
they're usually hidden and they don't
even expose a user interface it's it's
just in an implicit interface that by by
browsing the web you'll you're reporting
back to Google and everything because
people using are using Google Analytics
or YouTube or Google Maps or whatever so
so I think we can't actually say these
these are only problems in the big sites
yeah
like your the argument about interfaces
are demanding obedience would be an
essential as problematic if there were
or it seem like you're saying they'll be
less problematic if there are more of us
producing those interfaces like if if
the task of like who's owning the sites
and who's using the site is more equally
distributed among I don't think that if
all of us build our WordPress blogs
everything would be fine which is
happening less and less by the way yeah
yeah and and and you know if we continue
along the the previous medium being the
content of the new if they think about
the mobile apps and how the web is
becoming the content of them so yeah
this is I think it it has to do with
with literacy and I and I and I actually
think it it has to do with political
imagination like can we imagine a
different relationship and I'm not I'm
not making I don't think we can't do
that because we haven't thought of of
challenging the tcp/ip protocol I think
there's a lot to do even even before we
challenge the tcp/ip and I'm not trying
to challenge this a pap I'm far from
being in these levels of of action or
technological levels I think there's a
lot to do with both tactical both
tactics and strategies that are
inspiring politically as well and
technologically and UX eclis and so on
just an example I thought I wanted
really drives me insane in terms of
modern development of design is so we've
all known BBC online right we've used it
maybe for news
sources etc now anybody here has an app
it's mobile app I mean it is like back
to TV land
I feel even less engaged less powerful
less able to learn for example you can
read the article but there's never
related content or links to the embassy
of Nicaragua and the Embassy of us were
having issues but stuff like that right
there's no there no sort of comments or
or even a name of the person who wrote
it or a people who wrote it and I feel
like here we are after the 90s and the
first 10 years of 2000 after we've seen
this sculpture explode see this content
being created by all of us see some
people percolate up and being new types
of journalists whatever and now I feel
like easily reversed so I have an answer
for you that might actually address what
you were the answer that I haven't given
you I am working on a client project and
and this I was this is public radio in
Israel and when I was when I was talking
with with the the company that built the
previous site that were now redesigning
I I said we will need an API as a part
of the new redesign and and the same
company was supposed to build the new
site as well and they said we don't want
to build an API for this for them if we
build them an API they'll be able to to
get rid of us and and I was like what
like I can't believe you even allow
yourselves to say that but but it really
the good news is that this company is
not going to build it and and but there
is a future that we can get to that is
not very far
where instance where we all instead of
providing web sites we would provide
api's so your blog
would would be exposing an API to it it
actually was like that that was our RSS
it didn't we
I think when RSS happened and since that
kind of died it we didn't understand it
yet because technology wasn't there yet
the Ajax was act the X was for XML it
came after III I think I think this is
still valid and I think it's becoming
valid valid again ten years or so after
that now there is this need for for us
to to expose api's and and to allow
other people to do other things with
different interfaces over different data
I think thing I think this is this is
something that that I can I can see a
trend towards that and that it would be
a very interesting place for both for
data literacy and interface literacy
when you talk a lot about the literacy
right so one approach to these I mean
there are assumptions or decisions or
just sloppiness in these interfaces that
that restrict what I can do with it
obviously the sort of personal response
is build tool gets to a lot of people by
their own interfaces which you've done
now does that is that primarily an
argument to response about literacy or
or argument or response to say a like I
was able to make my own interfaces so
now I'm liberated from at least the top
layer of restrictions that were imposed
on me this is sort of a an arguing about
utility or a meta argument about like oh
now I know how to build these things so
I've become empowered in general to
think about the assumptions and what I'm
allowed is not love to do i I think it's
but you know you know the answer is both
but but but I think the only way to get
to the first assumption the one about
literacy is full utility because because
this might be an interesting debate to
have but until it becomes an actual like
that that's why I like about book
I need that I used that the fact that
book bureau not only recommended other
places to buy but actually sent me to my
public library is super powerful
it's super powerful it was I was in I
was in a concealed consumerist mode and
it sent me to a civic mode like that
that is and and and there was value
financial value and civic value for me
there so that is what in same with that
block plus in a different way of civic
value not block plus you wouldn't find
this much but it does value for its so
it's solving a problem it's a and while
doing that it's it exposes the the the
differences of interest between me and
the site itself so so yeah I think I
think there should be there should be
more initiatives that you think about
services in that sense that are not only
not only about literacy or a political
statement about information but also
about you know what do people want your
example and that one foster truly like I
brought Plus is providing utility for me
and has none of these sort of like
activist end points right where's your
ad nauseum is providing utility if it
doesn't lock in your feedbacks in the
blocking but then it's making this
aggressive stance to say hey I'm also
going to try to disrupt the system that
I'm checking out rather than just
checking out of it and I think a number
of the tools that you mentioned or that
I can to give in my head or more of the
I'm checking out of this yeah rather
than the I'm checking out and I'm trying
to like mess it up for everyone else so
that's a problem that I have with a
privacy debate it's super depressing
like there is something we didn't go
online to to hide we we go online to
communicate we go online to
express ourselves - it's supposed to be
this we enjoy that it's it's fun it's so
short the whole privacy debate and it it
gets people to eat to either hope for
the best or know that you're that you're
being [ __ ] but that's just how it is
or you you're mctavey enough to to
encrypt every every little thing that
you do and to use exactly the right set
of tools to to circumvent any attempt of
data being collected on you by someone
who you don't know and there's something
so so much of a stick about it's this
thing and super depressing it's no fun
I've never enjoyed protecting my data
and until and until we've started to you
know to go the the complete other way
with ad nauseam the whole idea is that
we want to be expressive let's be super
expressive let's be let's celebrate it
let's perform it and to tell you that if
you want me to tell you that it's a
solid way of avoiding data collection no
it's not it's definitely it's not going
to compete with with the latest
encryption algorithm in the next data
security conference nobody but it is
trying to compete with it with this idea
that security is something for for for
activists a kind of extreme activists or
terrorists or or a uber geeks or or
whatever it's it's something we need to
change the language around that and and
come from that at that point where
people want to be that expressive point
that is playful that is kind of and it's
also it's not only protecting myself
it's actually inflicting pain on on the
in and getting back to the to the point
of of
leverage which is what we're lacking
there because because the background of
ad nauseum is the failure of the Doudna
track Standards Committee so so the this
is exactly the the political process
that did not give give us a valuable or
a valid solution and well the solution
is completely is there right during a
track is is you can basically already on
Firefox you can already check a check
box even in Internet Explorer you can
check a check box that says you do not
you do not want websites to build a
profile on you the only problem is that
they don't don't respect that that's
what the committee was what was built to
to set to set the rules of how how is
this check box going to be respected but
apparently three three years after it
started the company is sitting on that
on that committee are there to make sure
it never it never it never leaves the
ground okay so so times up so thank you
for sure
[Applause]
you